women are 47 more likely to suffer  severe injuries in car crashes because  safety features are designed for men 33  000 girls become child brides every day  women in rural parts of africa spend 40  billion hours a year collecting water  at the rate we're going it will take 108  years to close the gender pay gap as of  right now only six countries give women  equal legal work rights as men just your  friendly neighborhood feminists trying  to knock down toxic masculinity doing my  best  god safety features on vehicles are  designed for men he says i don't know  what he's talking about as for child  brides that is a real problem in the  world take that up with fundamentalist  islam  women in rural rural africa collect lots  of water okay  what are the men doing how many hours do  they spend hunting or farming or  performing other manual tasks it's rural  africa how do you think it works there  [Applause]  gender pay gap well that's not true  because the gender pay gap is a myth  gotcha